welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home pulled
off a true nerd christmas miracle by
bridging with the past eras of the
spider-man franchise and opening the
multiverse to crazy possibilities new
histories and future timelines that we
never thought possible now the movie has
been out in the world for a substantial
amount of time now everyone is talking
about it and i assume if you took the
risk of wandering onto youtube that by
now you probably know the who and what
of what i'm hinting at but the truly
interesting parts are the how in the why
so whatever you have seen online if you
have not seen spider-man no way home the
film yet spoiler warning before i
continue so yes the rumors were true
past peter parker's tobey mcguire and
andrew garfield do portal into this
movie and they're not just quick cameos
the film spent several scenes catching
up with these characters in the lives
they lived so i'm gonna explain what
happened to these guys and what happens
to them and their converted antagonists
when they return to their native
realities and how that completely
revolutionizes the future of the mcu and
the sony verse and by the way you can
support the channel and get the perfect
holiday gift to celebrate the
spiderverse with all of our great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com some
awesome no way home designs and our new
limited edition strange entanglement
shirt again
newrockstarsmerch.com okay when we last
saw toby mcguire peter parker and
spider-man 3 back in 2007 he had
overcome venom and harry osborne goblin
who died in his arms a traumatic event
that he refers to in this movie but the
important lesson that he learned was
that he forgave sandman flint marco for
his involvement in uncle ben's death and
after he had turned off mary jane he
throttled back on the dance floor a bit
with a more apologetic slow dance and no
kiss suggesting that these two still had
a bit to work out and now we learn that
peter has aged up into a seasoned mentor
who's gone through quite a bit he
encourages andrew garfield that he
actually is amazing and worthy of his
own happy life toby says that he worked
out things with mary jane he also says
that he spent many years thinking about
an anti-serum for norman osborne and he
says that he had gotten stabbed at one
point but most importantly he realizes
that his webbing coming out of his body
makes him a freaky exception to the rule
of spider-man who is supposed to use
mechanized web shooters he's like that
homeschooled kid who thought that
everyone pees in the shower it's all
pipes meanwhile andrew garfield peter
parker hints at some dark places that
his character apparently went after the
2014 amazing spider-man 2. that movie
ended with peter and gwen stacy
defeating elektro but that version of
harry osborne goblin led to gwen's death
fall in peter's poorly timed whip that
caused gwen to hit the ground peter
stood vigil at gwen's grave throughout
the seasons like a whomping willow until
a video of gwen's graduation speech
inspires him to get back on that horse
and save a kid from paul giamatti's
rhino but now we learned that that
friendly neighborhood optimism was
short-lived this peter never really got
over gwen's death and stopped pulling
his punches he says getting bitter and
reachful it's not explicitly stated but
it is at least implied that he might
have beaten someone to death or nearly
to it that 2014 film was setting up a
big sinister six event to come after it
with gustav fierce and harry osborne
plotting to assemble a team that would
include the rhino lizard doc vulture and
either mysterio or craven the hunter and
there were rumors that that next movie's
plot would have involved resurrecting
dead characters like norman osborne and
captain stacy via cloning yeah just
sounds like a nasty gritty future for
that andrew garfield peter parker that
could have ended with him giving his
former best friend the skutt farkas
treatment
toby maguire peter parker on the other
hand had his own future for a fourth
film in the early storyboard stages from
sam raimi with peter apparently gonna
deal with the sinister six lineup that
included bruce campbell mysterio and
john malkovich vulture hopefully
something a bit more lighthearted on the
other side of that dark chapter with
venom but again he does get stabbed at
some point interestingly andrew garfield
also asks if magic is real in this
universe too and he and toby's first
instinct is to thwip each other so it
sounds like one or both of them had some
unseen future involving magic or
multiverse mechanics remember some
doctor strange variant did exist in
toby's continuity doctor strange that's
pretty good
but it's taken i know i know spiderman
no way home just gave us the perfect
holiday gift and i think we need a way
to celebrate the magnitude of this
occasion well our merch partners at epic
hero are stepping up to release the
biggest shirts of the year not like in
size but you know in like they're a big
deal i'm very important my apartment
smells of rich mahogany they have
multiple new shirt designs inspired by
no way home strange entanglement is the
newest member of their limited edition
latest obsession line it looks so cool
they also have a new spider polo the
special successor to their mega hit loki
gator polo it's a perfect gift for the
nerd who likes to break up the t-shirt
rotation with an occasional collared
shirt you know it gives it gives some
structure to this undefined unknown
region but there's also a sick sinister
six shirt in the style of the usual
suspects movie poster and of course way
more spidey merch on the way really they
have all kinds of shirts and hoodies and
stickers other merch inspired by loki
sheng chi other properties including a
new kingpin inspired shirt long live the
king celebrating wilson fisk's return to
the mcu in hawkeye and of course there's
also official new rockstars merch with
our logo some cases with my name if you
ever see me in public and you're wearing
one of these i am legally required to
high-five you so what you gotta do is
sign up for their newsletter at the
bottom of their website to get notified
about the latest merch drops and check
out all of their incredible products at
epicheroshop.com
be your own hero these are the once
hypothetical timelines that toby maguire
peter and age garfield peter are now
returning to however the events of no
way home changed all of these characters
in ways that likely resulted in new
branch realities forming in the
multiverse norman osborne green goblin
is returning to his 2002 movie timeline
at changed man but he is still a
murderer who had already killed his
colleague dr strom the oscorp board of
directors their military partners and
several others sure he would likely
escape his death in that greenhouse but
oscorp would be rudderless his son harry
wouldn't pick up his father's
anti-spidey legacy because you know no
goblin mirror goes to corrupt him
arguably this timeline would not have a
doc ock either because harry probably
would not have taken osgorp in that same
reckless direction of experimental
investments that his father was into
meanwhile the doc ock of no way home
returns to a separate timeline than the
one that norman returns to in otto's
reality norman still died as the goblin
but otto returns as a changed man back
in control of his mechanical arms
however tragically since otto said that
he left right as he had peter by the
throat that would mean the moment of his
return is right when the fusion reaction
was already way out of control meaning
that redeemed post no way home doc ock
would still have to drown himself to
stop that reaction flint marco returns
to a separate timeline where both
osborne and octavius were dead
essentially the same continuity of the
end of spider-man 3 except now he does
not have his sand materialization powers
so really no sinister six future for
that guy similar deal for dr connors
reese who returns to his 2012 era
timeline with andrew garfield peter
parker connor's probably in jail but
with no lizard mutation this could even
before lizard had struck captain stacy
meaning it's possible gwen's dad would
still be alive in this new timeline max
dillon returns to a 2014 timeline with
his new hunky appearance but no
electricity powers probably back to that
moment in the electrical columns which
might give enough time for gwen stacy to
leave safely before goblin got there but
with all of these it is important to
remember that andrew garfield peter and
toby maguire peter were separate
incursions beyond those villains that
warped in from later points in those
alternate histories because doc awk
remarks that toby maguire peter looks
older therefore the timelines that these
two peters return to are also separate
from the ones that the five villains
returned to and those peter's absences
even for a day or two resulted in a
shift of perspective for those two men
that likely alter their destinies from
where they were headed that means doctor
strange's spell and peter's interference
created at least seven new branch
realities that were not in the
multiverse before eight if you include
eddie brock venom so any sense that you
got the ending of no way home was just
resetting the multiverse back neatly to
where it was before as the acting
sorcerer supreme would say wrong sir
wrong and imagine that coming from the
new sorcerer supreme who is womp sir
wong the upcoming film doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness revealed its
first teaser after the no way home
credits and it heavily implied strange's
actions with spider-man and no way home
of course along with his choices in
doctor strange infinity war end game all
of these destabilize the multiverse so
badly that it is now beyond repair or as
mordo calls it desecrated so we are not
necessarily done with the worlds of
tobey maguire andrew garfield or any of
their foes they are all now part of a
quaking cross-pollinated multiverse in
which they all face new destinies so
with that in mind can we please now get
an andrew garfield amazing spider-man 3
the man has earned it and if mj deserves
a return i love you from tom holland so
does peter number three again celebrate
this spider season with our new strange
entanglement shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at e-a-vos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you